[Music]
this isn't the star wars that we're used
to it's the spin-off star wars film
rogue one where a ragtag team of rebels
band together to infiltrate an imperial
base steal the plans for the death star
and then they all die oh yeah spoiler
alert if you haven't seen rogue one yet
but it came out in 2016 so i think we're
fine rogue one is one of the better star
wars films disney has released since
their acquisition of lucasfilm in 2012
but it seems to be mostly overlooked
whenever people talk about star wars
whether it's because it's a spin-off
because of its troubled production or
because of actual issues with the film
itself people seem to have forgotten
about rogue one to understand exactly
why this is the case let's dive into how
the idea for rogue one first came about
john knoll known for his work on the
star wars prequels and the pirates of
the caribbean franchise as well as for
being co-creator of photoshop was the
one who first pitched the story for
rogue one with a story centered on a
single line from the opening crawl in
the original star wars film during the
battle rebel spies managed to steal
secret plans to the empire's ultimate
weapon the death star his original pitch
was titled destroyer of worlds and it
featured a mostly militaristic
self-contained story knoll pitched a
considerably low budget for the film
even suggesting that they recycle sets
from the force awakens there were
several changes made from knoll's pitch
to the final cut we received including
saw gerrera with his somewhat
haphazardly constructed darth
vader-esque suit who was not in the
original pitch as well as director
krennic who was originally supposed to
be scarred terribly on the face but
instead we got the beautiful face of ben
mendelsohn the only characters from the
original group that stayed the same were
jyn erso and k2so both of whom only went
through minor character changes
gareth edwards was brought on as
director known for his previous work on
the indie film monsters and 2014's
godzilla later in 2016 though tony
gilroy was brought on for a seemingly
large amount of reshoots gilroy even
went so far as to say that the film was
a mess before he came on there are quite
a few things from the film's trailers
that didn't make the cut and it seems
like these reshoots and other potential
production issues may have been the
culprit whether or not these changes
were for the better we may never know i
do think however that these changes late
in the game for rogue one's release
could be a factor in why the film tends
to be forgotten or overlooked since the
directors were likely focusing on the
underlying themes of the film and
whether the film was too dark or too
light they seem to have missed the mark
in three critical areas first of all
we're given a passive protagonist in jyn
erso rather than causing things to
happen moving the plot forward things
happen to her jyn first witnesses her
mother's murder then she's recruited
into saw herrera's forces then she's
imprisoned then she's rescued from
prison then she's basically forced to go
on this adventure to get the death star
plans none of this happened because of
choices she made to move the plot
forward so rather than giving us a
motivational sympathetic main character
we got a somewhat one-dimensional
passive protagonist it's this kind of
passivity that can make characters a bit
more forgettable and is likely a
contributing factor as to why rogue one
tends to be forgotten about the next way
that rogue one's creators miss the mark
lies in the common phrase show don't
tell take the first scene we get to see
felicity jones as the character of jyn
it's never shown to us who she has
become since her mother's death or how
she was imprisoned we're just told a
list of what she's done in the past not
shown possession of unsanctioned weapons
forgery of imperial documents aggravated
assault escape from custody resisting
arrest and we get no reaction from her
whatsoever when these crimes are listed
later we're only told about her history
with saw gerrera and we never get to
actually see how this time impacted her
fundamentally since the film tells us
all the things we should know about
these characters rather than showing us
it leaves much of the film's dialogue
feeling pretty dry and without purpose
yet again making the film a little bit
less memorable lastly and most
importantly rogue one fails to build
character investment by the end of the
film we should be fully invested in
these character stories and in their
futures but it's hard to feel bad for
the characters when they all die in the
end because we aren't fully invested in
them yet it makes the sacrifice these
characters made seem a lot less
significant and more like the single
line from the original opening crawl
which barely even mentions them i think
this lack of character investment stems
from the fact that most of their actions
in the first half of the film have
little to no consequences for instance
when the pilot is subjected to torture
from the weird alien thing his mind is
basically broken later in the film
though he snaps out of it and is able to
continue helping the rebellion there are
many things like this in the first half
of the movie where actions don't really
have consequences this lack of
consequences and audience investment in
the main characters has caused many
people to basically forget about the
entire first half of rogue one in the
second half of the movie however the
main characters seem to have a much
better purpose and actually have to face
the consequences of their actions the
film really does regain momentum during
the second half and shows us how a star
wars spin-off can achieve some really
great results one of my favorite things
about the film is that we finally get to
see a star wars story that's not focused
on the skywalker family we get to see
more ordinary people doing simply
extraordinary things there's no jedi no
love story and no skywalkers also
there's no opening crawl instead we open
with michael g aquino's spectacular
score which he wrote in a
record-breaking time of just four weeks
we also got some absolutely stunning
cinematography from greg frazier where
he's able to highlight the war aspect of
star wars in both dark and gritty shots
as well as in light and beautiful shots
we get to see the grey area in a galaxy
where things always seem to be black or
white especially in the character of
cassian andor who is set to get his own
series on disney plus later this year
lastly i just want to mention a couple
of things that i love about this movie
first things first k2so is hilarious and
i hope we get to see more of him in
andor
i'll be there for you
said i had to
next up darth vader's castle on mustafar
way cooler than i could have ever
imagined
be careful not to choke on your
aspirations
director
next krennic and his death troopers i
love ben mendelsohn's take on krennic's
character and the death troopers looked
absolutely terrifying and it's amazing
lastly the hallway scene
chefs kiss utter perfection darth vader
should always be seen like this he
should be known as the most terrifying
person in the galaxy and this scene
could not have been done better not even
when it's done in lego although rogue
one has some pretty serious flaws that
cause many people to overlook the movie
when they think about star wars i'd say
the good things the film brings to the
table certainly outweigh the bad
ultimately though it's up to you to
decide whether rogue one is worth
remembering and whether the film's pros
outweigh the cons i find that answer
vague and unconvincing
anyways that's gonna be all for today if
you like what you saw check out the
video on your screen for some different
content or drop a comment below on
something else you'd like to see also
don't forget to like and subscribe as it
truly does help me out and thanks for
watching rocket riley
[Music]